the Joe Rogan experience mm well you
know police honors we have such a
complicated relationship with them cuz
we need them and we don't want to do it
I don't want to [ __ ] run a goddamn
comedy club but we need one you know to
have some guys dealing with a bunch of
maniacs like us day in day out every
week coming in and telling jokes getting
drunk and smoking weed in the green room
and all the chaos is essential to the
artful yeah the existence of the comedy
club is essential 100 percent you ever
get scared that the young people don't
really go to clubs
don't [ __ ] with clubs yes yes I do it's
gonna change the business model like in
the next decade well one of the
beautiful things about comedy clubs
though is that we all use them like even
if you're doing arenas like you use
comedy clubs you use comedy clubs to
exercise like Chappelle comes in all the
time does the belly room that's a 70
seat room that dude just rolls on in it
would be half into it yep and he'll do
forty [ __ ] minutes and that is so
critical man it's so it's so important
to get that work in that's why I don't
like when a lot of the vets attack the
as they call them Instagram comedians
[Music]
because the club will book them and
they'll go well the live [ __ ] was
trashed it's terrible and it's true for
most of them it's not the greatest
performance because they haven't had the
chops yet yeah but they sold 300 pay
tickets and everybody ate and drank what
do you think is keeping the lights on
for your 30% selling capacity as to come
back in next year yeah and the next year
to go from 30% soul to 40% sold they're
not making no money off it uhmm but if
these IG comedians can come in and at
least help keep the lights on I think in
the greater in the greater scheme of
comedy there's more good than bad I
agree it comes from that and also for
like there's there's a there's a level
of ignoring the tools that they've been
able to use to get an audience in lieu
of the fact that they don't put a new
stand up on TV anymore let's it's
contest [ __ ] Comedy Central just started
with the put the lab at the cellar [ __ ]
but
other than that I mean it hasn't been a
lot but no-one's even watching TV
anymore
I mean the numbers on regular TV
programs are so low now like if you're
doing a set on Conan like what is what
did we win over this right like the
numbers are like less than four hundred
thousand people watch it a night yeah
that's a lot that might be laughs plus
three yeah I might not even be just live
there might be life plus DVR over there
yeah next three it's crazy so no one's
watching anything anymore if you can get
onto a stage but the way I feel about
Instagram comedians or YouTube comedians
is if you're doing stand-up you're a
comic you might be a shitty comic and
you might be a famous shitty comic
because you're famous from vine or
whatever the [ __ ] it is but who you're a
comic like it's whether or not you
decide to become a real comic and
actually do the work and put in the time
and then one day be look I hope we see
these YouTube comics and they're [ __ ]
terrible and then you go to see them
seven eight years later and they're
murdering they're crushing
great timing great premises I'm like we
got one we got one we need more
this is a hard gig think about what you
had to do when you were starting think
about you traveling around all those
[ __ ] things getting on a bus to do
open mics had to open like once a month
that takes a kind of grit and resolve
that most people don't but this [ __ ] is
like hazing where the old heads feel
like well they didn't suffer the way I
suffered
therefore your success is invalid I
don't take that I didn't do it the way I
did it this is the only way to do it the
game evolves that backs the points of
access it's like it's like comedy is
like to me it's like a [ __ ] grocery
store and you've been in line you've
been in this checkout line and then a
new checkout line opens and then all
these [ __ ] just cruise through that
checkout and you're still stuck yes in
the same waiting to get a Tonight Show
set line and the Instagram line opens
and people just start whisking through
to success and you don't know whether or
not to change lines or stay in this one
you know the beautiful thing about
comedy is you don't have to get out of
the line you just open up a new line
open up an Instagram line open up a
YouTube lon you can do all those things
in waiting in line
long as me so modern a get to leave the
store you know you have that jealousy
that little piece of jealousy when
someone has not been in line as long as
you leaves the grocery store before you
that's comedy now it is but it's wasted
energy you can't think about that you
can't like you should think about that
the same way you think about someone
having success in some field that has
nothing to do with yours like if someone
is a Nobel Prize winning scientist like
[ __ ] I could have done that but you did
it's really the same thing just thought
of that
yeah it has nothing to do but some
people are like that some people see
someone with like a startup some
internet startup and it makes a billion
dollars they get angry they get angry
because but don't go [ __ ] do
something don't worry about what other
people are doing it's a giant waste of
your energy yo I read a book rebel
without a crew I think it's arm I think
Rich Rodriguez I think his thing is his
name and he was a filmmaker and he made
the I can't remember the name of the
movie but it was the prequel to what
became desperado oh yes
yeah and you talked about just shooting
that [ __ ] gorilla and for essentially
pennies less than ten thousand dollars
shot a whole last film and walks through
how we cut the corners and then you
think of how to shot paranormal activity
for like fifty five thousand dollars
fifty or sixty thousand dollars the
first paranormal activity was dirt cheap
they shot the first saw for a million
dollars in 30 days in one building whoa
every and every scene in the car they're
just shaking the [ __ ] camera and jump
cutting billion-dollar franchise getting
reboot it now like that like when I see
[ __ ] like that I don't get jealous I go
oh [ __ ] I need to go and [ __ ] gorilla
some [ __ ] together yeah so that's why I
started trying to learn like in video
editing audio editing and all that [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]